uh we're now at
2:00 uh so uh we'll make a a prompt
start
uh good afternoon everyone and welcome
to today's planning committee meeting uh
we're on one
application be receiving planning
enforcement service progress report
which will be taken on the exempt side
of the agenda I am happy with this and
intend to take the business in the order
set out on the
agenda uh item one on the agenda have we
got any apologies Alan yes chair um
councelor S Forces has given us
apologies and he's substituted by
councelor m jant thank you
chair thank you uh are there any more
apologies non received
chair right the second item are is uh
Declaration of Interest members are
requested to declare the existance and
nature of any
disclosable disclosable Peary interest
and or other interests not already on
the register of interest in any item on
the agenda and withdraw from the meeting
at the appropriate time do any members
have any interest to declare yeah can I
declare an interest as I sit on Clos
Town V chair and I've been advised I you
know I can stay for the presentation but
soon as it gets to the discussion stage
then I will leave the room okay thank
you councelor I'll um we'll give you
time to leave after the presentation
thank
you we now have the minutes um of the
meeting held on Tuesday the 3rd of
October uh are we happy there are a
correct
record second yeah all those in
favor all those
against and I'll abstain because I
wasn't
here motion has been
carried thanks colleagues that brings us
to the main business for the meeting our
one application before we start I would
like the clerk to explain for the
benefit of members speakers and those
watching on YouTube how we will deal
with them
thank you chair this is the procedure
for considering the business of this
afternoon the chair will introduce the
application then ask the planning
officers to deliver a brief presentation
to
members just to confirm that there have
been no late
representations after this as there are
no speakers at today's meeting the chair
will open up the meeting for questions
to officers
a debate by the committee and finally
determination on the application by a
vote the votes will be taken by roll
call finally members this meeting is
being live streamed and recording will
be placed on the council's
website please note that others may
choose to copy this recording thank you
chair thank
you uh let's move now to the first
application well the only the
application uh I won't read out the
entire description uh but just to say it
refers to various developments within
Clay Cross uh really relating to the
town deal um it's application number 23
stroke
00601 in line with our normal practices
uh I'm going to test the planning
officers to give a brief presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
I will allow the officers to complete
their presentation consequently members
unless you have any point of order that
you feel cannot wait could you please
reserve these or any other questions
about the process until the end so I'll
now pass you over to grahe Cooper uh one
of our planning officers thank
you thanks chair thanks very much uh as
I said it's quite a long-winded title so
I won't repeat that out but essentially
the title is as what's on the screen so
so it is Works permission for major
regeneration Works which form part of
the council's bid for Town Fund to
deliver projects in Clay
Cross so members yesterday who attended
the virtual site visit provided a full
Suite of plans an extensive number of
photos taken from around the site and
around Clay Cross we've not received any
late
representations and there are no
technical reasons as to resist the
proposed
development so the main issues for the
application are laid out in the officer
report to members and the recommendation
by officers is to conditionally approve
the proposed development subject to
agreement of a legal agreement to cover
travel plan monitoring contributions as
required by darish County
Council so this first slide illustrates
the application site shaded in Orange it
covers a large area of Clay Cross Town
Center so the application site extends
from the commercial units to the north
as far west as High Street East to
Broadley and South to the clock tower
building adjacent to the extra care
facility which you can see at the bottom
of the screen in a h
shape so this next slide shows the this
is the latest amended plan for the
proposed development The Proposal can be
broken down into a simple kind of
bite-size scheme so I'll go through each
of these points in turn so the first
area to focus on is the Redevelopment of
the clock tower building and the former
Baptist Sunday school so this is
referred to the blue building and that's
referred in the report as building a or
block
a the second part of the scheme is the
16 new commercial units or incubation
units as referred in the officer
report we got a formation of a new
public open space between the commercial
units and a New Town Square on the left
hand side between the Clock Tower and
building
a we've got a pedestrianized section of
Market
Street as shown on the
plant and we've also got to the north
we've got the reopening of Bridge Street
and some minor Works to the proposed to
the bus
station so I'll now deal with each of
the each of those in turn on the next
few slides so first of all we have the
proposed Works to the clock tower
building as you can see from this Slide
the proposed Works involve the removal
of some elements to the rear of the
building and construction of a new
library extension so you can see the
proposed Library works it's the grade
out part of the plan in the top right so
metal cladding is proposed to the
extension so this next slide we have the
proposed Works to building a block a you
can see from the slide that the proposed
works here involve the forming of a
forward projection extension and Upper
Floor extension to the building the
southern elevation here will front onto
the proposed Town Square and metal
cladding is again Pro proposed to the
extensions that you can
see so this next slide is the design of
the proposed commercial units these
units constructed from red brick and
have an asymmetric roof
Construction
so this shows the position of the
commercial units around the area of
public open
space this space connects Broadley to
the east to the clock tower building and
the Town Square to the
West so next we have the proposed
pedestrianized section of Market Street
on this drawing you can see the oneway
section from High Street to Bridge
Street will be closed off to traffic
with bards the street resurfaced and
this will Connect into a further area of
public open space to the southeast and
that in turn will then flow into the
proposed Town Square which you can just
see kind of grayed out in the bottom
right and corner of that that picture
there finally this slide illustrates the
proposed changes involved to the
reopening of bridge streets traffic you
can just see the the road the grade out
area to the top of that screen so
that'll be reopened and traffic
reintroduced along that
route
so members yesterday as I discussed
earlier we're shown a full range of
photos I don't intend to go through all
those photos again but these are just a
few key photos from site and this first
one's taken from Broadley is looking
back towards the clock tower building in
the central of central of this picture
you can see the listed Church in the
background and the Smithy Smithy Care
Facility that's on the left hand side
there
so this view is taken from the access
road which leads from Market Street to
Smithy Brook View it's looking back
towards building a land behind the
Harris fencing that you can see will be
developed to form a Town
Square so this view is taken from Bridge
Street looking back towards building a
that you can see on the Left Behind the
traffic lights just kind of poking back
through the trees you've also got the
clock tower building centrally on this
photo and buildings on Market Street
just on the right
there so this is just a current view of
Market Street looking back down the
oneway system so this will be this will
be this section will be
pedestrianized in this final photo just
shows the current situation on Bridge
Street where the road will be reopened
to the rear of the commercial units and
the bus station is just seen on the
right hand side
there so these last couple of slides are
slides that have been provided by the
development team and these give artists
impressions of how the public open space
and Commercial units will appear after
completion of the development so this is
looking from Broadley back towards the
clock tower building and these are you
can see the incubation units the
commercial units either side of the open
space the second view is from the
proposed Town Square so looking from the
southeast Corner looking towards the
clock tower on the left and the
redevelop building
a and that concludes the
presentation yeah
councel yeah okay thank
you uh right then colleagues um as we
have no speakers on this application we
will move straight to questions to the
officers as always I would like to keep
this part of our proceedings focused on
getting clarity about any points you are
not sure of once we have done this we
can then have our discussion about the
application based on all that we have uh
heard and
read Council OT I'll kick it off shair
with the
my my thoughts for the officers to start
with is can you tell me if they Mak in
Market Street pedestrianized is that is
the ESS onto the High Street an air
Street just a couple of well one just
past it is one way onto there onto is it
Bridge Street and the next one after
that I think is Elden Street or air
Street I can't remember the name of them
that's been blocked off getting onto
there so I assume that the road will go
through by the bus station and come out
out where the lights are at
Tesco that that looks quite obvious to
me is that right
G yeah that's correct yeah yeah so how
how are you getting out then is that
going to be the only way out back onto
the High Street to go to O
alred because obviously Market Street
would be the one that he came from North
Wingfield or wherever unless you cut
across Broadley and come out
elsewhere uh you know then that's going
down through all hous Estates that's
going to be congested I want to know
what um what the highways have come up
with for you for for erress to that Main
Street yeah so I believe the information
within the transport assessment does
show traffic instead of going up that
section of Market Street can either
follow the road round to the traffic
lights near to to Clay Cross and then in
turn left back towards the Tesco Petrol
Station or traffic will go along
Broadley down to the traffic lights at
the end is it thanet Street yeah down
than Street along Broad and thanet yeah
so yeah the the transport assessment
does does discuss the the movement of
traffic and whether it be displaced but
I don't know whether you use it
regularly and they're pretty much all
day every day and they are pinch points
that is going to be such a struggle to
get out on those roundabouts and onto
the main road is there no option to open
up the one that's closed off I don't
know if it's s or Elden Street or
something like that I think it might be
Elden I just see only I just see only
two routes out back onto the main
road and broadly you can't get out onth
street at Best of
time can you just give me a second just
to look at a map so I just want to get
get my facts correct first before I go
into I'll put this off and let somebody
else have an ask but I think the the
traffic for me is the main one I quite
like the the
application
yeah
CH we're just trying to to clarify that
point for Council Elliott so if there's
other questions from Members we can take
this in the meantime if not I'll move on
to uh ask Council Le to for question in
a way slight slightly um councilor
Elliott I just wanted to also point out
that that route the than the broadlees
route is also the major bus route
um I should think there's a bus every 10
minutes so you know it's quite a narrow
road so obviously it does get very very
busy um also worries me a bit slightly
this comment about slight improvements
to the bus station because in my opinion
that bu station isn't fit for purpose it
needs major I mean you can't find
anywhere in there at the moment times or
information for any boss at any bus
stand so I'm presuming it's going to be
all electri
electronically you know like most bus
stands are I'm just hoping there's going
to be a great Improvement on the bus
station because it is you haven't a clue
if you rock up and are looking for a bus
to somewhere you don't know which stand
to stand at what time to do or anything
it is it is the one of the worst bus
stations I've ever been through and I
use public transport a
lot just on the the bus station issue
shair the the main alteration will be to
allow for the reopening of Bridge Street
it will mean that there's
a a revision of the the bus stops and
the one nearest to the new Junction with
Bridge Street would be lost so would be
left with the the four main stands in
respect of the The Wider improvements is
our understanding there will be those
improvements but whe they'll go as far
as Council liot as um suggested chair I
don't know just um in terms of the
issues that Council Elliot discussed and
gra just looking for the specific detail
of that the reopening of Bridge Street
to facilitate that other the way out
instead of coming down through Market
Street is in conjunction with the
highway Authority in terms of how how it
will all works so they're comfortable
that it will work in terms of how the
traffic will move but as as far as we
understand it and graes just checking
this the the ways out will be either
down Broad Street or Market Street to
the East Broad least to the South or yet
yes up to the the roundabout near to
Aldi at the the north I'm just a little
worried Adrian that I know Clay Cross
right now is is an absolute bottleneck
you get that the wrong time and it's
it's backed way over the roundabout that
takes you down to Tesco on the main road
you you can't move there in the morning
and trying to get out onto it right now
up Market Street if you've not got
courteous drivers you struggling you're
struggling to turn into toward towards
Chesterfield all day every day it's not
and it is a tight Junction I know and
it's not the best of Junctions but I
think you'll just bottl neck a few more
with fet Street in broadley's and the
roundabout where the garage is where
where CMC is chville motorcycle center
so I'm a bit worried about the that and
I think C get alluded to the buses she's
absolutely right it's it's tight as h on
there but when the buses turn down broad
whichever way they come
in I don't think the you I agre agree
with it you can turn down it yes of
course you can they'll open the road so
you can but that doesn't mean it's going
to accept all the traffic that's
there the the offset chair would be that
you're losing the the one way of Market
Street that's that's what's being lost
just that one way up onto the the main
a61 yes that that traffic will be
displaced elsewhere or we can advise
members chair that this has been done in
conjunction with the highway Authority
who advises that it this the scheme as a
whole works as it's as it's
presented take a r check on that
one I've got one question for officers
uh just regarding
the just come back on just on one point
on that chair sorry I missed that but um
in terms of the the highway elements
they will all be done in conjunction
with the the highway Authority Under the
278 agreement that will need to be
entered into in terms of amending any
roads or altering the way the traffic
uses them so ultimately we're
comfortable as as planners to raise that
again with the highway Authority but
that would have their final say so if if
that's any consolation to to council ell
chair in terms of making sure that it
does work just pulled it on a auto route
Adrian it is Elden Street and they
closed it off I would think 10 15 years
back but they closed that off when they
did the scheme that is there now so
maybe it' be appropriate to open it back
up rather than go down past the bus
station stand at the lights turn back
towards towards the garage and get back
onto the main uh playay cross drag to Al
and the Elden Street to be another cut
through to be another way of getting
through Maybe
maybe I just yeah I just looked at it
back in the day when they changed all
that they closed that off that was just
another route out how to Clay
across it's only the traffic issue that
worries
me okay thank you um my question is uh
regarding the um you know the industrial
units the new units that they
building um they're all sort of same
same the same size or they appear to be
on the drawer in
um is there going to be some are they
going to be adaptable so if people want
a larger premise they can take on two
units that will
be joined
together I believe from the plans that
they'll just be individual units but I
think that from talking to the project
team they will be the shell so if
they've got conversations with somebody
who wants to take on two units there
will be that
flexibility
thank you uh anybody else got any
questions officers
no while you're on the the issue of the
units gr do we know what they specified
for or are there any of them that are
there any particular kinds of Industry
you can't use in them I mean remember
the the one that we tried to get the pet
crematorium in one of them you know only
200 yards away you know is this going to
be an issue again so I'm just going to
throw that one in for
you so yeah those commercial units and
building a and clock tower will be fall
within the use Class E so it's quite an
open open to interpretation there covers
lots of things offices you know you got
food and drink you got shops you got
Professional Services so it covers a a
far-reaching
uses that can be used in those
buildings that that help okay is is any
anybody um has anybody asked for any
take upon on this yet or has it not been
has it not been put out to the public
for
that we have as plan as we haven't been
involved in the take up those buildings
I think that's something the project
team are looking
into okay no further questions uh right
uh thank you to that the officers um
this leads on to the final part of the
process our discussion about what we've
heard what we think and what we want to
decide but before going any further I
would like the clerk to remind us about
motions right thank you
chair please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
the vote is
taken if an amendment to a motion is
moved and seconded then that Mo
Amendment will be voted on
first if a motion is to be moved which
goes against the officer's
recommendations then the member who has
moved the motion must give the reasons
for doing
so the reasons for moving a motion
against officer
recommendations should comprise the
relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as
necessary if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls or in other words
it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved rather you will need to take a
positive decision through a further
Motion in favor of the recommendations
or a different course of
action this will be need to be approved
by the committee through another
vote thank you
chair uh thank you well uh right I will
now open the floor for
debate
Council anok thanks chair I agree with
Peter I think it's a great idea I think
it looks really nice but the travel plan
is it just Falls flat on its face
because they're cutting off the routs
there trying to get from broad onto
thanet street is a nightmare even in a
normal vehicle so anything bigger which
is going to channel everything there it
says in here which I know is what the
basis is that they're trying to get
people to use sustainable transport but
then they're taking a bus stop away and
buses into clay AC cross aren't great I
mean I live literally in the next
Village it's quicker for me to go into
Chesterville than it is to go to Clay
Cross because the roots so it's not
actually we're going to do potentially
something that could be great that isn't
going to get the take up and and
potentially is going to fall flat on its
face because the transport aspect of it
isn't sound um unfortunately that's the
only failing with it I think that to me
they really should relook at that and
then come back with something that's a
little bit more robust in terms of
getting vehicles in out Clay
Cross can yeah I'm going to stick same
again um same as councelor Hancock I
mean they're actually now putting more
shops off off Broadley so encouraging
more people to use broadly I mean at the
moment there's a vets um and a cafe and
The Fireplace shop and that's it on the
broadly put more shops on there there's
going to be more much more traffic to go
hopefully to go and use the shops that's
the theory so it's it just seems really
strange to me to put the shops where on
one of the narrowest off one of the
narrowest road with very very little
parking near
it thank
you nobody
else um and I think I think we've got to
remember that with the um Team have
worked with the highways department and
they can only go on the their advice the
highways department and they've looked
at this process and decided that it's
acceptable the travel plan that has been
put in place is acceptable so I think we
have to go with our advice on that and
not just go on his own little ideas of
what we think might be wrong with the
traffic chair I don't think our own
little ideas come into it I've had 20
years on planning and seen a lot of the
fers that we've dealt with with um with
the transport issues and the traffic
issues and the desktop um desktop
surveys in reality so I want to be
comfortable in my own mind that you know
we are asking questions about this
application and from what I can hear
right now we're asking reasonable uh
questions about the application because
we don't feel that the that the road
links and the structure they've got is
the one that's the best one should we
say that's my feeling I'm not speaking
for everybody but everybody can have
their own say and the debate but I don't
think they're little issues when it
comes down to a whole town being snarled
up with
traffic only my opinion your little
ideas my little
idea uh anybody else got anything to add
the
debate oh right um if that's okay case
um having heard everything uh today the
offer recommendations before us uh what
is the view of the committee on the
application I am now opening the floor
to
motions no
motions
chair is any we can sort of like propose
something it where it goes back to the
drawing board where we relook at the
sort of traffic issues that people have
got um more local knowledge have
raised um is any I mean you know reason
to this committee so more experience
than me that could come with a decent
proposal um you know we I think I think
my thing would be we don't want to throw
the baby out of the bath water but I
think it' be reasonable to look at those
issues that members have
raised sorry I was not raising a motion
as discussion
Adrian thank you chair the um as um as
GM just said sh a lot of work's been
done um both with ourselves as planning
officers and others within the project
team to bring this forward and it is an
integral part of the towns deal um wider
scheme if you like and and the work
that's been going on to seek to bring
that investment to Clay Cross so as
offic as we've come forward with our our
balance view in respect to our
recommendation and the impact that that
wider benefit will have as members will
have read in our report is as we see it
overriding just on the issue of the
traffic the issue um as Council Elliot
seems to be put forward I hope I've got
this right CC but is the not opening up
of Elden streets so having that that's
still blocked and that does formally lie
outside the redline site the application
site as it stands so there's no nothing
in this the the proposed scheme that
would would alter that
my is incorrect would be to if if
members are otherwise minded that the
scheme is acceptable to if you're minded
to to to approve it under those terms to
add a note in terms of the decision in
respect of the the traffic
management proposals in terms
particularly of Elden Street and ask the
project team in conjunction with the
highway authority to re relook at that
and they could deal with that under
their 278 powers under their their
Highway Powers but that wouldn't give
the planning Authority control to to
make that happen so there would be that
caveat on that but it would then in
effect
place the concerns that members have
have raised in terms of traffic
management that with the project team
and the highway authority to ensure that
they're convinced that the scenario that
caser Elliot's painted chair wouldn't as
far as they they are concerned arise but
have to be be clear with members that as
planning Authority if you were minded to
go down that path then you would in
effect be approving what's before you
and that we couldn't as planning
officers guarantee that the Elden Street
situation would alter
in
fruition through the chair Adrian I
don't I don't want to just get stuck on
that on me mentioning Elden Street
because I'm not saying that Elden Street
would be the be all and end all and the
and this the you know stopping those
pinch points being created the the the
point I'm making is that if you try to
turn right off Home gate right now onto
the main road you almost can't unless
The Pedestrian Crossing comes on or
unless somebody can L lets you out
you've got a whole new estate down there
and God knows how many houres being
built around Clay Cross they all decide
they want to come out that way I just
think the roads aren't capable it's a
bit like we all have the discussion
about Derby Road now bit that the wrong
time you're going nowhere are it's a car
park and I don't want Clay Cross to end
up a car park just because we've not
looked into the the road issue more
that's all I'm not necessarily saying
that Elden Street would be the be all
and end all and probably the residents
of Elden Street wouldn't want it but I'm
absolutely sure that you know we could
we could look it because I just think to
push everybody onto the roundabout did
they call it Harry Harry's
way yeah the the new bit if you push
everybody along there trying to get in
and out of Al is a nightmare now I just
you know I drive it all day every day
and I just see it I just see I can just
see foresee the issue we're going to get
I hope I'm wrong because I think it'll
go through I think the scheme's great I
don't like the road I don't like the
transport
issues
can thanks CH yeah I'm going to EO this
because the problem isn't just one place
because we're effectively diverting most
of the most of the traffic now down the
broadland stet street area which is one
of the most heavily populated because
there's a lot of old people's Bungalows
it's a lot of flats in that area it yeah
it's and it's tight it's a really tight
Corner that that Junction there you've
got the the big set of flats um behind
the vs it's it it will make their life a
living hell to be honest um it it needs
something else looking at we we can't we
need an alternative proposal I think to
to actually say do this not just accept
it on the hope that someone else is
going to going to come up with another
proposal if I can just come back on that
point chair members will have heard me
say this before so I apologize for
repeating repeating this but the the
planning test is that the impact of the
development on the transport Network or
in highway safety um apologies um
development should only be prevented or
refused on Highway grounds if there
would be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety or the residual
cumulative impacts on the road Network
would be severe so that would be the
test the residual cumulative impacts on
the road net would be would be severe or
there would be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety and the fact that roads
may be busy or difficult to to join or
you need to wait to join them in my
opinion wouldn't pass that test that
would be the planning test
so the the traffic and the way that
works may be busy and heavy and it may
slow the traffic Network down but does
it make it unacceptable in terms of
safety or is that cumulative impact on
the road Network severe and that that
would be the planning test and members
have talked a lot about inconvenience
and and the weight of traffic but
nothing yet in terms of what I've heard
that would hit that test in terms of
unaccept impact on highway safety or
residual cumulative impact would be
severe so so that would I just ask
members to consider that chair because
the the other option that you have if if
you're not convinced that the scheme is
is acceptable in this form would be to
either refuse the scheme or to defer it
and what I can can advise members is
that the reason for bringing it to you
this this afternoon is because the
impact of not taking a decision this
afternoon has been advised to as and
that may impact on the on the wider
project chair which is why we've we
brought it to to members this afternoon
so in weighing that um members need to
be aware of the the potential impacts of
that in terms of your decision
making
counciler uh thank you chair I
understand that when it comes to turning
down and app ation about the uh the
residual impacts being
severe um and the second test uh I don't
think uh planning members they don't
seem to be minded to want to turn the
the application down and and prove that
test I think it sounds like from what
people have said that the more in got
concerns about traffic flow and traffic
safety but not that it goes that far so
perhaps the the option that members are
looking for is the deferment and it's F
to be looked again looked at again I
don't know I'm not putting words into
other members mouths but I don't think
they're talking about that you know
meeting that turning down but I think
they're talking about uh lighter
concerns than that thank you
chair counil J i' just like to ask
through the chair my fellow members who
raised concerns uh would do do they see
these issues as
fixable I think people members have
raised concerns about the plan as it is
now
um I don't know
whether my colleagues would um see that
see there fixable
solution I think it's absolutely fixable
uh I don't know you know being not being
sat there on the highway Authority what
land they could use potentially how they
could widen anything potentially how
they can make it flow on on the end of
thanet Street and on the end of AR's way
AR's way I don't I don't know how they
do that it's just the volume of traffic
but but when Adrian says making that
test and and you know that's not a
planning application issue then I see
the safety of trying people trying to
get out of them Junctions when they are
impatient and there is that amount of
traffic an issue that's what I
see I don't think they're insurmountable
I just wonder whether there's another
option uh Council
L thank you chair uh I'd like to move
with officers recommendations with
conditions read the traffic
infrastructure is revised and
Revisited as a separate
item is that is that a motion that
you're putting forward yes yes
CH is that in line with what um Adrian
mentioned just like putting a note on
the document to uh to work with traffic
management to see if we can develop that
scheme it's similar to um discussion
that we just had chair that there is a
condition in respect of or one could be
manufactured and and worded to require
the the traffic management proposals to
be subject of of a condition and one
option would be for us to bring that
traffic management scheme back to back
to members for you to consider that this
afternoon so similar to to council laes
suggestion but with that caveat that we
will bring that traffic management
proposal and the affirmation of that
condition or the determination of that
in effect a reserve matter back for
members to consider um and at that point
you would have the opportunity of
assessing whether that had met
the concerns that have been raised or
the issues have been raised this
afternoon that would allow the project
as a whole to go forward but would allow
planning committee the fin will say in
terms of that specific element the
traffic management element so that that
would be our recommendation as officers
chair it's it's similar but but slightly
different to the way that Council lac's
um phrased it so hopefully that that
gives members a potential Way Forward
that would ensure that the concerns
weren't just left without challenged
into the future but it would allow The
Wider project to meet all its other
tests and
hurdles Council don't
uh just a quick question I mean I'm new
to this as I've been subbed in uh if we
go forward with those
recommendations um the gr's just given
is there a risk assuming that it comes
back we then vote it all through and
it's all fine is there any risk in that
regard to causing any delays or
significant delays uh to the town
planning project
itself and forgive me chair I'm not
fully of with the the project plan but I
in advising this afternoon I don't think
that would delay The Wider project it
would mean that those issues further to
any decision this afternoon would need
to be got into and and addressed quickly
that that revision but there are various
other pre-commencement conditions that
are set out in the decision that need to
be discharged in any case so they are
going to need to be addressed discharged
so I don't think if you followed that
course of action retaining that control
that it would delay The Wider project
but it would allow all the other
elements particularly the funding
elements to move forward I
believe uh does how does members feel
about that
suggestion moving progressing this
[Music]
forward so
what's the wording on this that we've
got the
Adria I'd suggest chair if if members
are minded to to support that as a way
forward and we would ensure that the
final wording of that condition is be
delegated to myself chair but in
consultation with yourself and the vice
chair that would be my my suggested Way
Forward okay counc just for clarity
because there was actually um when when
it was being discussed Adrian said oh
his differs slightly to what has been
saying what are we actually voting on
right now are we voting on because there
was a difference between what Tony was
suggesting and what Adrian was
commenting on so I want to know what
what we're actually voting
for the the um the element that I'm
suggesting is that a specific condition
is is actually worded in terms of having
the submission of the traffic management
of the The Wider Town Center being
controlled by condition which I think if
I'm I'm correct I think Council Lacy was
was talking about having the a more
limited element of
that I think that's right yes yeah so it
would would the condition would be
phrased something along the lines of
prior to any um development Comm prior
to the commencement development so it
would be a pre- commencement condition
details of the traffic
management of the scheme and its and its
implications for adjoining streets would
be submitted to and approved in writing
by the local planning auth and then
implemented in accordance with an agreed
timetable and and that would come back
to you so you would you would then have
the opportunity of assessing whether
that was sufficient in in your eyes as
as planning committee that thank you
Adrian can I just ask this question
quite simply does that mean even though
we go down that route and they come back
to us will they relook at the scheme
around Clay Cross Roads and the answer I
I would think in your experien is now
they'll just go ahead and develop it out
there and see how it
goes the I I can't say that they would
change the scheme I I can't give you
that that um that guarantee but what the
way forward that that I'm suggesting
would mean that you would retain control
over that and if those those details
didn't meet
your requirements then you would have
the opportunity of refusing that that
detail at that stage and saying that the
submission of those details was not
acceptable I just think I just think
once we give the go ahead to go ahead in
the in the way we've been discussing
then nothing will
change they won't they won't look at any
more roads in roads out or anything will
they they'll just go ahead with a scheme
and think we we've got hit
through it it it would be the same chair
um if if
I'm not saying you want to do this but
if you were minded to refuse the
application and it were
appealed then content could be given for
an appeal scheme so if if you went down
that scenario it would be the same
conclusion that nothing would would
alter all all I can say to members is
that we would put it back to the
design team and the highway Authority
with the comments that have been made
this afternoon but but you're right I I
can't revisit it
I'm sure they'll revisit it whether
there whether the outcome will be
different I can't give you a guarantee
I'm afraid I just I don't have that
authority to say that will
change no else well I'm going to put it
forward that we accept officer
recommendations with the conditions um
that Adrian has mentioned uh to work
this through uh and obviously bring this
back yeah it would be in consultation
with yourself and vice chair y That's
fine right CH is that really just an a
clarification of the motion which has
been moved and seconded which is
essentially uh along those lines that
the officer recommendations be approved
subject to a condition being developed
um in consultation with yourself in
terms of a precondition around the
traffic conditions and sort of uh uh
management of the site which would then
be reported back to
committee was that the essence of it
members it would would be the um details
submitted pursuant to that condition
Alan yes absolutely
yes right thank
you uh right we'll take a uh a vote on
that uh proposal then um and we'll do it
by roll call so to on name right thank
you chair councelor Chon
for councelor
Cooper councelor gerant for councelor
Elliott councel
Foster councel Hancock
four councelor
harthon
four councelor Lacy
for councelor
liot councelor Peterson
7even for and three abstain chair the
motion has
passed thank you thank you
members uh and
now
sorry yes yes absolutely that's what I
was just going to
say
for
uh right the members uh we'll move on to
the next item on the agenda uh which is
the presentation on planning appeals
which Adrian Kirk comes going to deliver
so you Adrian thank you yes thank you
chair members will see that there's a
number of appeals were submitted over
the past four weeks and the decisions on
those will be reported in due course
there just been the one appeal decision
received chair the past four weeks and
that relates to the develop M at Coach
Road Overton as always chair I very much
recommend to members that you give the
appeal decisions we receive a read
because they always provide some
interesting inclusions and the way that
things are being determined and in this
instance particularly as the application
was for a retrospective development the
interesting thoughts that the inspector
had in respect of it and its impact on
the character of the era and it will now
be for us to determine what what action
we take in terms of ensuring that the
land and the buildings are put back to
the where they should have been or were
intended to be in the first in because
consent was granted for a scheme on that
site but it wasn't delivered in
accordance with the the approved details
so happ's always chair to take any any
questions but I think it's as simple
as thank you chair thank you very much
uh Adrian for that uh absolutely
excellent work uh when it comes to uh
sting appeals and especially uh if you
pass our thanks to Mrs wraith as well
for for the work she's done on that uh
can we make sure and I'm sure you will
anyway that when it comes to what we
learn from uh these planning appeals and
what what we gain and I know we
shouldn't look at them as wins always
but when we look at the support we get
from uh uh the inspector when it comes
to backing up your decisions you've made
or decisions we've made here can we make
make sure that we do build on them uh
and that members are minded that we can
build on these when it comes to Future
applications and we're able to you know
provide robust responses to the
community to developers when it comes to
you know sticking by our local plan and
sticking by our rules so what I'm trying
to say is things like this should give
us some confidence to be able to you
know tackle developers and Tackle things
like this thank you
chair if there there is some mechanism
chair you'd like us to explore with
yourselves in terms of learning points
happy to to do that if if you would find
that that useful um and we can have a
chat about how we might pick out any
learning points um from appeal decisions
and and bring them back to members if
that's um perhaps a conversation we
could have chair yes definitely yeah
Council Foster I'm not sure who uh who's
in charge whose portfolio it's in member
development but if you're looking at
planning training uh perhaps that could
be passed on to the portfolio holder for
member development because it's an
excellent idea uh when I was the
portfolio holder for member development
I made sure that dur during those three
years that I concentrated on making uh
defensible planning decisions as you
know Adrian and that's sort of thing
that perhaps could be fed on not my
decision but perhaps it could be fed on
to the portfolio holder uh as a matter
of training thank
you uh right thank you members um do we
agree to note the
report yeah
okay right uh matters of urgency uh
thank you as I have no matters of
urgency we will move straight into item
eight uh which excludes the public I'm
afraid thank
you I move that to the public public be
excluded from the meeting during the
discussions of the following item of
business to avoid the disclosure to them
of exempt information as defined in
paragraphs two and
five sorry you're uh audible there could
you thank
you as as defin in paragraphs 2 and five
part one of schedule 12a to the Local
Government Act 9 1972 as amended by the
local government access to information
variation order 2008 if we are all happy
uh then let's move on to item nine
planning enforcement service progress
report H can I just clarify chair uh has
this live stream
stopped
that